speaking by the way of the i guess the
front runner the democrat from
front-runner pete butterjudge he had
some thoughts
uh recently he was on state of the union
on cnn and he had some thoughts about
the republicans
who do not favor federally codifying the
redefinition of marriage now there are
plenty of republicans as we saw in the
house that were on board with it
but uh but that but the majority still
were not and pete buddha judge is very
offended and personally hurt by that and
here he is explaining why
this is really really important to a lot
of people
it's certainly important to me i started
my day as i try to do on weekends i try
to give chastain a little bit of a break
and
do breakfast with with both of our our
twins and
that alone that's no small thing as
every parent of small kids knows uh it
was one of those days where the tray
table wasn't quite
fitting into the high chair and i'm
trying to make sure that they're busy
enough with their little cereal puffs to
give me enough time to
chop up the banana and get the formula
ready and and it just
i don't know that half hour my morning
had me thinking about how much i depend
on and count on my spouse
every day
and our marriage deserves to be treated
equally
and i don't know why this would be hard
for a senator
or a congressman i don't understand
how such a majority of house republicans
voted no on our marriage on as recently
as tuesday hours after i was in a room
with a lot of them talking about
transportation policy having what i
thought were perfectly normal
conversations with with many of them on
that subject only for them to go around
the corner and say that uh that my
marriage doesn't deserve to continue if
they don't want to spend a lot of time
on this
they can vote yes and move on and that
would be
really reassuring for a lot of families
around america including
mine um a couple things here first of
all this guy's such an egomaniac i mean
they all are but especially this guy and
it's even more grating with him because
he has there's just no
basis for it for his ego like it has
nothing to rest on no accomplishments to
rest on at all it's like a small town
mayor who runs for president fails
spectacularly then then is given an
appointment
you know a
cabinet appointment for for no reason
other than the fact that he checks a
couple of identity boxes
and uh and so that's it he's a
transportation secretary
but he says oh they voted on my marriage
no they weren't voting on your marriage
you egomaniac that's not what the vote
was
there wasn't there wasn't a a bill on
the docket what what do you think of
pete budage's marriage
no specifically it's about the should
the federal government
redefine marriage
should we codify
the redefinition of marriage on a
federal level that was the question that
they were answering and some of them
said no as they should have said
and by the way
the people who answer no to that well
there's there's a number of reasons why
you might answer no specifically to the
question of should the federal
government codify it
but for the people who are
critics
of the whole uh you know
of the redefinition of marriage on any
level
they're not saying that your marriage
doesn't deserve to continue
what they're saying
is that your marriage
can't exist
because marriage is a particular thing
and
your relationship
does not fall into that category that's
the argument now i realize that's still
going to offend you and make you upset
but that is the argument
and it's actually a really important
distinction
as i tried to explain last week and as
many people have attempted to explain
this is all a question of definition
and the idea for thousands of years is
that marriage by definition
is an in-principle procreative union
between a man and a woman
and it serves as the foundation of the
family which serves the foundation of
human society that that was the answer
that was the definition that's what it
was
that's it
and then people like pete budjich came
along and said well it's not that
anymore and then the question in
response has always been well then what
is it if it's not that
pete boujee hasn't answered that
question
he says well my marriage deserves to be
treated equal to to other marriages well
but but it but equal means the same
is it the same
is
your relationship
with jason
is it the same as it is it in principle
in its substance
in its function
is it the same as my relationship with
my wife and the answer is no because my
relationship with my wife
has the potential to create new human
beings
and yours doesn't so
that is a difference
right that's a difference we can all
agree no question about that's a
difference
is it is it an important difference is
it a definitional difference
i would say
absolutely it is
of course it is
but even putting all that to the side
you know he's he says that well how
could how could we talk about
uh they would sit and talk about
transportation policy with me and then
and then go and vote the way they did
why should so what
so they can't talk about you cannot have
a productive conversation about
transportation policy with someone
unless they agree with your definition
of marriage
unless they affirm
your relationship
as a marriage you can't talk to them
about transportation policy see that's
your problem that's your hang up it's
not theirs
i guess for those republicans they
figured yeah okay well i might not agree
with this but we can still talk about
transportation why can't we
you're the one who sets down kind of the
the ground rules here and says well you
have to agree with everything about my
lifestyle or we can't talk about
anything
[Music]
that's your problem
that that's that's uh that's you
deciding to do that
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
that wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this youtube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on spotify
apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts